fans of the show know we love bud light
seltzer and you know what we love more
than bud light seltzer when they sponsor
the show they are the presenting sponsor
you know about bud light seltzer it's a
delicious hard seltzer from bud light
with no bud light in it each one is only
100 calories 5 alcohol by volume and
gluten free and now they've got the
perfect flavors for summer with the bud
light seltzer lemonade variety pack and
the brand new bud light seltzer iced tea
variety pack you can try them together
which christian did the other day and
make your ideal alcoholic arnold palmer
with a bud light seltzer ice tea and
lemonade mix pack or dive into the good
vibes of yesteryear with the retro
summer pack and retro summer icicles
there's that cherry limeade that's my
favorite flavors and you know you can
combine there's a peach iced tea and
lemonade you combine those together get
a peach arnold palmer stay tuned to hear
more about bud light seltzer's newest
offerings and a little more about us and
our summer memories later in the show
but now the show
[Music]
i've been spending a lot of time now
that we're you know people are getting
vaccinated and we're seeing family again
and i've been seeing my nephews and
being around them because my one
nephew's three being around them really
reminds me of being that age and
the thing i remember most about that age
is just how curious you are about
everything about the world
everything is new and different and when
i was that age
i wanted to know about everything i was
really curious and i had a book that was
all about unexplained phenomena all
these mythical creatures like bigfoot's
abominable snowman
the chupacabra and i was just fascinated
by this book and whenever we were on a
family trip if it was a forest woodsy
area i would look for bigfoot and how
hard did you look i looked i looked for
prince i thought i might see him
footprints footprints not prince the
musician oh no no i never looked for
prince i was not that into prince i was
much more into bigfoot
uh loch ness i couldn't believe that
there was photographic proof of bigfoot
and loch ness and now of course we know
both of those have been debunked
unfortunately it was really sad to read
but ufos
uh the government came out and said that
ufos actually do exist and people it was
like third page news let's chat more
about that on the show right the show
yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you are listening to life is short i am
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
and with me as always is my brother and
co-host uh christian i think you're
right about the absurdity of the
government announcing that ufos so wild
exist and it's absurd that that didn't
have
traction i know i know i mean there was
a lot going on with politics obviously
and all that and social unrest and there
was a lot going on that humans
were concerned with you know on this
planet but very clearly that means that
somebody's flying those things it means
that there's alien life i mean i can't
even say it it's like it's really hard
to wrap your head around that i know
what was that twilight zone episode we
were watching oh uh to serve mankind to
serve mankind yeah and of course the the
great twist don't don't ruin it spoiler
alert no no no don't don't ruin it all
right it's it's a great episode and it
reminded me of this uh
alien
chat you know a lot of those old
twilight zone episodes are really
relevant today a lot of them were um
inspired by
george orwell and aldous huxley and some
thinkers who cautioned against
big government and uh you know
bureaucracy and technology taking over
you know what else is a great
representation of the supernatural and
extraterrestrials
uh in television form oh let me guess
go um the muppets in outer space
yes
a former friend of the show neil
degrasse tyson current friend of the
show great example yeah cosmos carl
sagan oh i know what
the x-files that's right hit show on fox
it really put fox on the map cemented it
sure did yeah i mean the simpsons did
too i think both at the same time
because like the simpsons were geared
more yeah there was like more family
x-files was like for adults it was
really well it wasn't like adults i
wasn't like was dirty i was four adults
and uh star jillian anderson
anderson what did i say julian anderson
oh i didn't mean to add a little t
i i tried to pull off of it she played
scully yeah and her partner mulder
mulder that's hard for you i can't say
mulder no you're saying moulder
like a thing that's moldy it's gotten
even moldier
mulder mulder there you go mulder was
played by
our guest today yes yes our very special
guest david duchovny i'm kidding i know
it's duchovny david duchovny who um
you know i was also then once i saw
zoolander i was so surprised to learn
that oh [ __ ] he's so funny he can be
funny because he was so dry on that show
x-files he was also the star of
californication which was a very good
show david also is a very bright man in
addition to being a known actor he's
he's a bright he's a thinker and he is
now
a published author he's written four
novels and he now has
a fifth work it is an audible original
it's uh short form content it's i would
say it's longer than a short story uh
shorter than a novella yeah so he
employs his acting skills of course
because he's reading the thing and he
does different voices he does to plays
different characters um but it's really
uh it's about the pantheon it's about a
guy
forced to quarantine so it's really uh
apropos it's called the reservoir
and it's a great listen it's really well
written and it's it's only about two
hours long so it's uh
you know highly recommend if you have a
little road trip to take or it's it's
really good a lot of people be taking
road trips this summer and you know we
love audible
that's right friend of the show as well
so uh check it out the reservoir and
before you do that don't do it now now
listen to the man himself the iconic
he's iconic right i think so iconic
david duchovny
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
hey
david
hi justin how are you
nice to meet you likewise pleasure thank
you for doing this
that's my pleasure i just came back from
um this is not about me i wanna i can't
wait to talk to you but um i'd rather
talk about you oh really okay well go
ahead i feel weirdly compelled to tell
you that i uh just came back from a
physical my checkup how are you well i'm
i'm i'm okay um
which is how he delivered the news uh
you know in the finals you're okay
you're okay
yeah he he kind of couched it a little
bit he said look you're healthy you know
it's like that
um i want to know the
the why the tone but he it was my first
um
my first prostate oh really yeah
do you how'd that go um it was very
sudden it uh it was something of course
i've thought about free
because it shouldn't be well the
really the lead up to it was sudden
they're right like we're gonna do this
yeah okay it was just yeah it was that
it was okay now turn around starts
putting on the gloves i saw the glove
went on and
of course you know it's something you
think about for
i mean i you know years i've been like
i've known
dreams come true
yeah
i knew the day was coming but i
it was the i it's just a whole i was
telling my friend afterwards i said it's
not that it happened it's not the
physical it's not the insertion the
thing it's that it's the context in
which it happens you know that there's
no
it's
it feels it feels like it's secretive
even though it's just like we're not
going to talk about this we're just
going to do it you know like i'm going
to surprise you
it's a very weird
thing because
well what what at least what my doctor
doctors have done in the past is they
narrate it while they're doing it so
so
so it's like i'm inserting my finger in
your anus and i'm like yeah i i kind of
go oh yeah i use context
yeah and then i'm i'm uh i'm i'm
rotating uh clockwise with my house yeah
i got that too
and i but i think that's you know what
they're supposed to do is like you know
talk you through because you're you're
back oh that's funny my guy did um
almost the opposite he was he was making
jokes about he's a really fun i love him
he's um but he had just been talking
about the jets while he was feeling my
balls
and because we
we root for the jets and um
and he keeps it really casual during
that part of the process which i'm used
to but then he started making jokes
about how i might i should play someone
you know don't play someone who goes to
prison or now if i do i'll
yeah yeah yeah
i don't wanna
that for me the worst moment was uh
when it's all done
he kind of takes off the glove and
throws in the garbage like it's the most
disgusting
thing
ever and he hands you he hands you a
bunch of uh
of kleenex to like white people i didn't
get that i didn't get clinics and i've
never i've well they use a ton of loot
but i've never wiped myself in front of
another person except for probably my
mother or father so i remember
it's just a weird kind of thing to do
and yeah it's shameful there's there's
shame in it uh it's infantilizing it's
like yeah but i didn't like the way he
threw those yeah
so dismissive
uh
yeah so and you want to say like well
what'd you expect
you know that's not what it's for
um did i disappoint you i disappointed
yeah well there is it's funny at david
that you say that because i did i
remember i did sit with this in this
moment of um there was definitely shame
if i'm i'm trying to like identify the
feeling but there's definite shame and
like and and
the most vulnerable you're
so vulnerable um
well i mean you know we're we're taught
but also
there's a natural
revulsion to our own uh
feces and our own you know dirtiness you
know i mean yeah it makes sense as it
has to want to keep keep away from that
uh and so i think all that comes into
being it's just it's just you've just
exposed your
primal nature both cultural
you're dirty you know you're you're
and it's like all it's happening in this
bright
room with somebody you kind of know no
you know that's so interesting i know i
wanted to like you could do a whole hour
we could all
we should why i know it's it is really
interesting and that's what struck me
was like uh just the psychology of it
all too i wanted i wanted to sit and
have a talk with him about it um which
we did a little bit but he said he's
he's so used to it obviously right and
to him it's just second nature and i
imagine anyone who is used to that being
um
used for different things that part of
the body
yeah so you want you're saying you
wanted to feel special and and he didn't
you didn't make it maybe maybe you're
just like another another dude that's
coming you know
with another glove and did you have to
use the gloves
maybe next time um i hope so i hope so
well uh yeah thank you for indulging
that that's it's uh it's now it was
obviously on my mind
not my favorite um where are you david i
see it's i'm in new york okay okay cool
i
um in my apartment i'm trying to make it
as dark as possible it's a beautiful day
beautiful i know thank you for doing i
know it makes it even nicer that you're
doing this you're talking to me about
bottles
um
yeah yeah you were raised in new york
right i didn't know that yeah yeah i was
i was raised on uh 11th street second
half of sleep like low risk crazy to me
that's yeah yeah the difference do you
know louis guzman i know guzman grew up
near there and oh i know who it is yeah
yeah
oh yeah he's uh
lived he probably lived the same time uh
in the same neighborhood yeah yeah well
it was uh is he puerto rican yeah he was
a little further down he was on
c b and c yeah yeah it was a it was it
was oddly it was like a mix of puerto
rican and ukrainian yeah wow
wow
no kidding and uh
and oddly also i happen to be half or a
quarter ukrainian but had nothing to do
with
why we were why were you we're just at
um
well we lived on 18th and third and they
tore down that building we had an
apartment and a little walk up and they
tore that down to build a big building
that's there now and so we had to we had
to move and uh my dad found uh you know
bigger apartment there are three of us
three kids
uh i love you know so
down we don't wanna be stereotyping him
now but i imagine that was there were
they bohemian were they were those it
was that
uh no my dad i mean my dad probably was
bohemian by nature and he did identify
himself as a writer even though he had
he had a nine-to-five job at the
american jewish committee the ajc
uh and he was he was kind of a
speechwriter
and i and
so he had like a steady paycheck but
because he had a family and um he always
wanted to
write he was always
considered himself a novelist and he did
write short kind of political satire
books to make a little money as as as we
were growing up like little little books
that fit in your pocket that would just
kind of kind of abuse the political
figures of the day
but uh he published his first novel when
he was 73 years old two years before
before he died wow how and was that did
you see a difference in when he did that
work i mean in in his
demeanor was it was it something that
was uh
in terms of him being fulfilled
yeah well he was he was i could tell it
was
a real matter of pride for him that he
had
that he'd finally uh pulled it off and
he actually
he came
he came to i was in l.a living in la and
he was living in paris he retired
to paris
uh which was his favorite city he was
born in brooklyn but um
he came to la to do like a book tour
and it happened right after 9 11
and there was
there was brett brentwood books there
was the duttons and brentwood
that used to be in brentwood that he was
going to do it at and
literally the only people the audience
were me and my brother
and and his wife uh my dad's wife oh my
god
and i felt so bad for him and yet he
went through the whole
yeah as if we were strangers
that is really fun then he and and and
then he opened it up for question you
know
and again and i was like i was like
uh where do you want to go out to dinner
after this
and you are
um
that's really funny okay
uh okay do you have children can you
tell me about your grandkids you know
uh
but but it's i like that it didn't deter
him i like that it was um
oh he had he had worked his
whole life really yeah
he was going to be damned if he wasn't
going that's awesome you know
and i resp i totally totally you know
the time the time i was like oh this is
weird and now looking back i'm like yeah
yeah yeah and that that he yeah the same
level of commitment to an audience yeah
um
did he continue to be politically
outspoken like were family dinner tape
where like thanksgiving meals just well
he
he was politically outspoken in the way
of
just like i hired like he hated all
politics and all politicians
i mean he was definitely a you know a
left-handed uh liberal
but you know he didn't trust any of them
and uh you know it was just really he
was just a satirist yeah
and i i he never was politically active
so he wouldn't have taken to like
twitter or something he wouldn't he
wasn't into like the loudness of the the
anger he might he might he might have to
make jokes right
right and then he that then he would
have said something stupid and got shut
down right it's right when a short-lived
tweeting career like like the kind of
thing my dad would say is
and this is the kind of thing that gets
you canceled these days is
like he was born on 9 11 and he told me
once that he was very upset that his
birthday had been ruined i always
wondered that
i've wondered that about people and i
was like dad i don't think he could just
say that to me
yeah uh yeah i know those things that
like i know back in the day i guess uh
he
i think about stuff my grandpa used to
say he would have been you know
within a matter of days would have been
canceled
um hours maybe uh so he was so when so
your parents when you decided to pursue
acting with
and i i know i think it's a pretty
well-known fact that you went to you
went to princeton you went to an
incredible school you you were a great
student um
i and i always wondered this about
people who in your who were in your
position when they decide to become
actors
because i had a similar situation my
older brother went to princeton and
yeah so so there was that
my parents were so proud of that
obviously and it was such a big deal for
him to to do that as
as it is um
that there was something about him
wanting to pursue acting he acted there
but it was like
with that kind of degree that they felt
like it was a bit of a waste yes did you
do they have that at all
absolutely not my not my father so much
because my father
you know as i've described him uh
consistently he didn't really care about
princeton i mean he cared about reading
he cared about writing he cared about
the life of the mind
but he didn't think that you know ivy
leagues had any corner on that market
you know that you could that you could
live your life that way regardless of
where you went to school or whatever and
of course he's right but
when i became an actor he he said i
didn't think you know because he left my
mom when i was like 11. so he didn't
really
wasn't really around after i was 11.
so
when i became an actor he said you know
the kid that i knew
you know i felt like you wanted more of
life you know like this makes sense to
me you know like the kid that i knew
i don't think
wanted to be a professor at a young age
you know
so he kind of understood that about me
my mother
comes from
small town in scotland you know no no
money fishing village
you know and the way out of
poverty
in
her generation was education it was the
only or the priesthood you know there's
like two ways
my dad did both you went to the seminary
to get an education too and became a
professor yeah that's so funny right
right where's they're not scottish but
they're from uh upstate new york and
they're they're they're yeah they're
uh german and italian descent yeah but
they were immigrants yeah right or
children remember
so
my mother was uh
very adamant about education and and
also and also very taken with
the brand you know
sure
it's hard not to be so
yeah i guess i mean i guess i i went
there because i could or whatever and i
thought
i thought that it meant
i remember because my son is graduating
tomorrow from high school and i remember
i was trying to remember this day for me
so many years ago and i remember
thinking well i felt like
at least i belonged somewhere you know i
i was getting to go to princeton and
like
i mean i had like
gotten through that
yeah yeah
and that i had bought myself another
four years of that
right right right
well and at least i was going to have
that degree at the end of it but um i
mean it's weak but you feel like the
protection of friends totally i like it
yeah
we all succumb to that in life over and
over again
so did you act there david did were you
doing no no no kidding not at all no i
played sports i was just wanting to be
an athlete now
and and write i thought yeah what sports
were you
i played basketball and baseball huh no
kidding so i'm guessing point guard and
not so well not so hectic
i should have been a point guard i
should have worked on my ball handling
skills but i was what everybody wants
was just a six foot shooting wow no no
but nobody wants nobody no oh well i
mean we were just talking about the jazz
back in the day and jeff hornacek and
uh yeah stockton was my guy my my
favorite um
my good friend uh jess walter who's a
terrific novelist uh lives in spokane
and uh and plays and knows uh uh
right
yeah no kidding wow
it's funny we were just talking about
you should have just walter i know i'd
like yeah okay
he's he's a he's a great
conversationalist a storyteller and a
wonderful right is he available right
now
okay yes i think that's well we'll do a
swap out he can replace the replacement
oh um that's so funny yeah i
i was i always imagined stockton as
being just because he looked like that
in comparison was purely superficial
that he was um
that he was kind of a
a nerdy i guess a nerdy guy like
kind of like he could be like david
carradine revenge of the nerds or
something you know and uh as it turns
out he's very
i mean i've never seen interviews with
him and all the other players even
jordan is like hey he's he commands
respect
well jess told me that you know i guess
stockton's baby's six huh you know he's
not he's not yet
but he said his when he puts his hand on
you like if he wants to strip the ball
from you he said it's like a
a vice like he's got big hands and it's
it's like his forearms are just made of
iron and you can't yes oh i bet
you get the same feeling about chris
paul like why chris paul can do it yes i
i feel i feel like he's just really
strong here yes it's that and which is
just all control that's why those guys
were all control
and it's god-given it's you can't like
build up your hand in the gym you know
right there's no hand machine yeah
that's true well that's now i'm thinking
of you in zoolander when you did that i
like oh god yeah that uh
that's that's you and
it was that it's also surprising to me
at the time because i knew you so
specifically i knew you so well as this
um
you know from x-files and from
from california movies that were
uh darker and and
yeah i bet that surprised a lot of
people was that was that your impetus
for doing it or was it just like oh no
fine i'm gonna have fun with stiller and
those guys
well as both i mean my evidence for
doing californication was probably you
know like uh i want to try to be funny
and i'm tired of
people thinking i am the way i look or i
have the way i've appeared in certain
things
um
so
the zoolander came
i actually think it came to my wife of
taya my ex-wife at the time
for something and i stole it and i said
let me read that
and then
and then i called ben and i said hey you
know i want to do a part in your movie
and he was like what about how yeah you
know
i don't know she'll make up her own
[ __ ]
she'll make up her own mind she refused
to read it she threw it in the trash
and then uh
he said okay you know you can do uh like
there's two parts
that are open what was the other one
it was the one that vince vaughn oh oh i
think his brother yeah his brother
so i think i i you know i i just
i said okay well let me try the handmade
screw and then you know that was ben was
really kind to just say cool you know
yeah that was it when you dave when you
read a script like that is it i mean it
sounds like you were me he took to it
immediately but but do you think of it
being as being uh special is this like
you read that because now of course the
movies are classic but
i always wonder and i'm trying to
remember my own experiences reading some
of those things um
but do you do you know right away
dodgeball stuff like that yeah
it was hard i know real framework
reference though and like i didn't know
i didn't know i mean i knew
it it was a lot it was it was way
broader that i that by nature right
you know so so it was like
uh
but i unders but i could see some of the
writing was great and and uh you know i
just remember reading like the hand
models
dialogue where he called himself a
finger jock you know [ __ ] like that
that's just that's just like gee yeah
you know that's that's not even a joke
it's just like that's good
yeah and and um
you know that's another that's another
911 story because that movie came out
right after 9 11.
and and so it was not a hit
that's right um
in fact they had to digitize out i think
the trade center the trace i don't think
they had to fix
i didn't mean to reference california
california like that's what i was
talking about yeah yeah which was one of
my favorites uh
such a
dark bunny and clyde story for those i'm
not telling you for for those of you who
haven't seen it if anyone if anyone's
listening um
i don't remember oh it's
great and
yeah but that kind of thing was that
that i think that was before maybe even
x-files right yeah it was
i was doing red shoe diaries right which
i've also seen
uh zalman king uh we're gonna have him
on
zamin was
so good too yeah because
i don't know if you've had this
experience in your in your acting life
especially when you're young or younger
i mean i because i started kind of late
i was never like you know 18 and having
to do yeah but i was
i was already like 27 wow
and um
solomon was just such an enthusiast
like
every every day you went to set
and and since i was so uh inexperienced
uh i believed it like he he he would
tell us we were doing this great work
and and we were making this great thing
and it just was like the best feeling
that's right and
and i'm i'll never not be did he have an
accident he passed the passenger yeah no
no
no he didn't have an accent uh zom zaman
i think was also from oh oh oh
yeah he and he was he'd been an actor oh
i didn't know that he
like like he was on the old like dobie
gilles show you can see him guest
starring and like gilligan's gilligan
he made i mean he was incredibly
prolific i mean he
did so much uh that's right i remember
you were on those things so
you didn't know i just want to go back
for one second i want to get to that
because i used to watch those all the
time curious about that world that kind
of like um
what would you call it salmon because
soft core i mean it's not even that's
what people call it
but that's like
i guess the words you're not saying it's
porn so i don't know i know
right right like so what is it like soft
r yeah like uh why does it have to be so
why is it left off
well there was you know it's funny there
was always a soft there was like a
gauze to the way it was shot well that
well that's yeah out of focus out of
focus
porn yeah out of focus and you could see
that they were kind of humping like a
lower part of the leg there was like uh
i always wondered about the mechanics of
that
those scenes you know um
but it was mostly just like
it was a have you never had a had a like
an involved kind of
i have but but never like that
graphic uh
one where it's like a prolonged
i guess like humping of something yeah
it's like you clearly they're on like
the lower part of the yeah i i think
we've we've just been closer to
you know we you know you uh you wear
stuff and
yeah but uh i mean i've done those
scenes with girlfriends at the time and
like
they're still walk
and now they have intimacy coaches i
know talk you through those but those
that must have been a whole different
beast i would imagine a movie like a
thing like salmon king's
stuff yeah i mean oddly i can certainly
talk about it but
my role in the in the show like we did
the pilot i'm not sure if i had a an
attack yeah
and then because because the stories of
my my girlfriend is having an affair so
they had the intimate stuff oh right
right and then she's killed herself and
i i remember getting her out of the
bathtub naked but that she's she's dead
at that point and then
i you know and then when we did the show
i was just like the bookend guy i was
the only guy you know with my dog
so you don't need a coach for that
that's right yeah
but my dog uh my dog was cool yeah
he had the most beautiful teeth and i
said to the trainer as we were working i
used to come down like when we started
to do x-files like 93 or four i was
still doing a red shoe diary so i was
doing two shows but i could i could come
down to la and shoot
red shoes i could do like six episodes
oh my god there's one location just to
book
just two bucks
amazing
we got on we got out of san pedro down
the docks nice and lonely you know
long lens
to death right and then and then uh but
i said to the trainer like this dog has
the most
beautiful teeth i've ever seen on it
though they're almost like human
he said yeah he said the other cat oh i
was like your dog get out of here it's
like yeah yeah okay was he [ __ ] with
you
no no the teeth were they were
really white and really symmetrical
really well now i think about it you
have nice teeth
well these are i knocked my teeth on
high school these are
these are man-made as well oh from uh
from playing uh from sports no no much
much more uh a less uh heroic story i
just fainted fell on my face do you
remember why
well my mother thought it was because i
didn't i never ate breakfast so after
that
after that i couldn't leave the house
just wheaties
shoving without eating an omelette the
size of my torso
[Music]
i had a summer bod going into the summer
but i've been trying to maintain my
summer bod a staple of my workouts has
been bomba socks i love them i can't get
enough of them i don't have a summer bod
but i'm still wearing bombas they're
great for lazing around as well they're
just so comfortable in fact i've never
really thought too much about socks in
general but these socks have really made
me appreciate
what really good socks can feel like
unlike other egg socks they don't slip
down ever i've been running in them i've
been really active i wear them all day
and i forget that they're ankle socks
that's how
secure they are they have something
called hex tech performance technology
they also are stitched with special
moisture wicking yarn we've heard of
that ooh i love moisture wicking yarn
there are temperature regulating vents
that allow cool air to flow in and
prevent overheating that's another thing
with my bombasan i've noticed my feet
never get like overheated they never get
sweaty and gross and they have that you
know that foot smell they also come in
different styles for every sport with
very specific design features to help
you optimize performance and keep you
comfortable no matter what you're doing
every single pair of bombus performance
socks you buy
they donate a pair to someone in need so
to date they've donated over 45 million
pairs of socks which to me is incredible
go to bombus.com
long today and get 20 off your first
order that's b o m
b a s
bombus.com long for 20 off
bombas.com
long
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
when was it that you decided you want to
be an actor after it was after college
yeah it wasn't when i was in graduate
school at yale i had started getting
interested in playwriting because
a life of other kind of writing seemed
so lonely
and i said yeah and at least at least
playwrights get to sit in the theater
and watch this true
that's true that's more communal yeah
yes so i you know when i started to
think about writing plays i started to
think about oh well i should probably
learn what it's like to
say words on a stage or you know like i
should i should know something about i
mean if i phone or write for that i
should know something about that so kind
of led me
you know to secure my curiosity led me
into that area wow okay so and and yay i
mean no better place yale drama and yeah
oh they had well you know the the hill
drama school is very interesting because
i was in the english department which is
a totally separate thing i don't have
the right analogy but it's like
you know if you have a ticket to the met
game and you decide you want to go to
the yankee yeah you can't just use your
message right right so like i can't just
go in to yell drama and say hey i'm a
yeah so that means
but they did oh really
they didn't they were like i was just
like auditioning
sitting there yeah they didn't oh and
there must have been some real heavy
hitters in in your in that class then
yeah i think so i mean i can't remember
i mean it's fair the name it's very
exclusive i know i mean that and julie
already out there
so
yes wow wow so um so then it becomes
this is something i can do
uh you discover that and then it's and
then
how quickly do you pivot from that to
i'm gonna go to la and try to get work
well i
i don't know that i thought this is
something i can do i just thought
i thought
i mean honestly i just thought
there's something here that i interested
in
you know it's fun like there's
yeah it's fun
and it reminded me of sports which i
wasn't playing uh yeah
just in terms of performance and like
stakes and yeah you know high pressure
tightrope kind of ugly
and then um
i'm not a high-energy like super
expressive you know like oh that guy's a
born performer you know but i thought
but i thought i had something that i
wanted to express even though it wasn't
coming out in the way that people said
right you could communicate a truth in
some way
i was i thought yeah yeah so
i wanted to at least get to the point
where i i
i wanted to see if that was true what i
was telling you that was true huh and
and again your parents are your mom at
this point is like you've already done
you've done not only princeton but now
yale so she okay with you
trying
[Laughter]
my mom was my mom was still not okay
okay i don't like it how do she still
exactly
she doesn't she kind of has a neutral
accent she doesn't have a new york
accent but it's not scary ah too bad
she's 90 she's 91 wow and um just the
other day i was i'm visiting with my son
and
she was bad-mouthing me as an actor and
my son was like oh yeah well you know
it's not working out too well for him
you know he can always change go back to
school and i was like i was like oh my
son is defending me what a great what a
great moment
my son is defending me against my mother
i mean
it's great i mean there's a lot of stuff
to talk about in therapy yeah or on a
podcast
yeah yeah was xbox just like a pilot
that came up that you were like yeah
this might happen and
yeah yeah in fact uh i had another job
that i was going to do which was like i
forget what that was funny to say yeah
it was like two scenes in a
in a movie of the week or something and
and
i had met the uh director
on twin peaks which i'd done and so i
felt i felt like
she was kind of doing me a favor like
she'd give me this job without
auditioning and i remember telling my
agents like you know i really should do
that job because you know i want to be a
good movie of the week
yeah and they were like
you know i know you have to do this and
it was really my manager uh it's no
longer my management she was for many
many years melanie green who said you
know you have to
you have to do this
and i was like well i want to be a guy
that like backs out of jobs and like
they
and the casting director got randy stone
i don't know if you ever
ran into him
he's dead now too um
but randy
he said to me and i don't know if he
said this to everybody so
he might have
but
he said to me when when there was all
this stuff about like oh david's not
really not dave's not going to do it
because he's going to do this other job
and he called me
and i wasn't like david de company it
was just like david isn't gonna do it
why the [ __ ] is isn't david gonna do you
know
david
yeah who the [ __ ] is david
the red shoe diaries guy doesn't want to
become the xbox guy
uh so
he called me and he said
i have only said this to one actor
before in my life this is the part yeah
yeah classic randy stone
and he said you will never
need another job in your life if you
take this job wow
and i said who did you say that before
you said
woody harrelson cheers when he came in
to read
coach had died oh my god
he knew i i wonder what it was i mean
obviously
it's easy to look back and say yeah of
course that's
clap it's a classic show it's part of tv
yeah and we don't know that randy didn't
say that to every cracker but he was
trying to convince right to do a job
he said it to mario lopez when he was
not going to do that
um exactly that's wow so
so that's got to be compelling you hear
that from a big casting director so
that's like okay
i'll do it
i mean i wanted to do it i
i just uh
honestly i just didn't know how to get
out of the oven
i let my agents do that so funny and did
that woman ever forgive you the director
oh yeah yeah she totally understood i
mean she was like what are you crazy of
course
go do a pilot right and uh
i
you know i i
that was at a point in
in our cultural history like this is
1993
and there was still more or less a
stigma of doing television right and i
and i consider myself a movie actor you
know so that was part of that too it was
like you know i don't want to i don't
want to do tv
movies and and x-files is one of the
shows that changed that totally iron
ironically
um but also also was fox right it was
like this little network like they just
started it's like nobody even watch this
phone oh yeah it's like in living color
and like simpsons exactly yeah that's
bad
that i don't did they have a simpsons
they did i think i think it was 90 or
89 90. but just started i mean like
that's what i remember about the x-files
really putting that network on the map
too it was hugely influential um and and
i can only imagine
what it must have been like then in the
wake of that kind of behemoth that that
level of fame and
the the
rabid nature of the fans and um but it
must have just been overwhelming
these days
the concept of like global fame is so
quick you know everybody everybody is
globally famous immediately right
but but i think at that point it was it
was just like was it right away david
you noticed okay it took a couple years
probably but you know when you're on the
inside of something it's like you can't
really
you can't really you're not really
judging because i'm just going to work
and trying to
i'm trying to like memorize my lines
and do and do good work i'm not sitting
around thinking
gee
but like then it becomes two which is
also a difference at the time now the
internet is so pervasive and it's how
people communicate but and i imagine
that show would have been
that would have been right oh my god
they would have gone nuts on online you
know would have been all this online
stuff but
there were there were chat rooms
like after a couple years that were yeah
chat rooms yeah um and i remember
thinking oh this fad this fab that's
funny yeah
um and and uh god said there's too much
to talk to you about because but i know
our time is limited i really want to get
to the um your audible original uh the
reservoir which i started listening to
it's so well written and and again like
this shouldn't be a surprise i just
sometimes i mean it's my own prejudice
about actors i'm like yeah that
actors aren't good writers
um well it depends it depends right it's
like i always say you know what people
you know i tend to agree you know like
but but i always say like shakespeare is
an actor yeah i mean i'm not saying i'm
shakespeare but i'm saying i'm saying
the greatest writer that we have
in our language was an actor primarily
that's so true so how can you how can
you say that i mean
what and what does it matter what
somebody does i know when they sit down
to write i know it's true yeah uh yeah
but having said that i agree with you
most actors
well but you're um
and yeah your command of the language is
really strong but it's also you paint
such uh
such detailed
such and at times very funny pictures of
this guy ridley um who's struggling in a
in
in quarantine i mean it also brought
back up a lot of my own
uh initial reactions to being in
quarantine i'm sure it will have that
effect on many people is that was that
the inspiration for writing was it was
was it simply like i'm stuck i want to
explore this well
weirdly it was towards the end of
quarantine and i was kind of sitting
around going what the [ __ ] have you done
with all this quarantine oh that's fine
you've got nothing to show for it you
know like like
i'm sure your your your enemies have all
written three novels and you know like
and you've just been like trying to cook
oh that's but i did yeah yeah
and
and you're you're such an [ __ ]
because like usually you work hard and
this past year was tough
obviously i didn't do much acting work
yeah
not a lot of people did and uh did you
are you usually very um
uh productive i mean you've written this
your fifth novel uh is your fourth uh
fourth well i have four novels but this
is uh i mean it's like yeah this audible
is the fifth publisher oh okay all right
um uh still yeah i guess i'm productive
i'm more like a
you know like a sprinter yeah yeah and
i'll [ __ ] work hard hard hard
and then i the moment passes and then
i'm useless yes yes my analogy i often
think of like anacondas because anaconda
is so rarely but when they do it's like
a bit you know they really go for it
some big deer cappy piss
and then you gotta digest that deer and
[ __ ] it out and and give it to the world
well the [ __ ] part is where the
analogy kind of falls flat but not all
the time
sometimes not all the time um it's
helped me so i
i have i have this uh
i live on central park west here in the
city and i have this amazing view oh wow
and i was just sitting
looking at it in the early morning
and i just started to have this idea
about like this
rear window
all the way across like fifth avenue
like obviously you can't see what's
going on those windows but because
everything in the pandemic was shut down
it's like what normally was kind of lit
up at night across the way it was dark
and i just started to think well what if
what if this guy saw one light and he
thought it was talking about
what if he was drawn out into out of his
safety and much like death in venice
like yeah he's drawn out with this
prospect of this woman beckoning him
across the park
and what happens you know you know does
he eat those strawberries like in devon
venice does he die of the plague does he
get sick and like all these kind of
terms like six feet under six feet away
they were all like bounced around my
head and it was just like such a lonely
um
time yeah you know the pandemic was
actually
it's an enforced
distance right literally literally aside
from being
isolated there's an enforced distance of
six feet between each person so
i started to think about
just the loneliness of it and then
this time of conspiracies you know
with the ballots that was also happening
i just thought
everything just started to kind of come
together in a fever dream for this guy
who has who may or may not have
coveted or a virus and so then is that
is there a
spark of excitement then david when you
do when it does start to uh codify
do you then start sprinting right away
do you sit down at the computer and just
oh [ __ ] yeah it comes
oh i don't know that um i start writing
before i know that
i'll start i'll start i started writing
a character you know looking out his
window and and thinking he's an artist
like i'm gonna make these time time
lapse
photos of the park and then people are
gonna know that i'm like a sensitive guy
an artist
you know he's a wall street guy so you
know people are going to see i'm
multi-dimensional right money maker so
that was kind of like how i started and
then you know
the surprise was much much i knew that i
was going to do a rear window thing
across the park but much of the other
stuff just came out of nowhere and i
find that as a writer and as an actress
i'm sure you'd agree when you surprise
yourself yeah
i love it
that's why i love when mistakes happen
you know i love yes um
using those things uh yeah it's
well got to too much i'm just uh quickly
trying to uh edit self-edits um
and why did you choose to make it audio
only david you had mentioned the the
four other books you wrote did you just
think this particular story would be
more is just more effective that way
just as a narrated thing
well
it was a couple things one was it was a
weird length it was like it was long for
short stories so it would be hard to get
that published magazines it would be
like the whole magazine right
and it was short for a novella it was
too short to go to my publisher and say
hey i want to publish this standalone
thing
so okay it was kind of a tweeter and
then i heard about amazon audible and
then i got excited about just like the
old
hey let's sit around the campfire yeah i
know i love it i know i know and you do
the other uh voice i love the other
voices you do you do some like really
good that must have been fun too just to
do the voices of these kids yeah well i
describe him as like a barry white yes
yes i can't get but i but i can try to
approximately yeah it's pretty it's as
close uh hey you gotta get something
yeah exactly yeah do you do impressions
of anybody do it do anything i i
i do very bad ones i mean i've done
like when i did snl i did richard gere
and i did uh jeff goldblum i just jeffy
oh man
yeah let's hear a little you know i'm to
ask you about um
i'm just going to ask you jeff goldblum
actually why
he is a uh decided to become a
vegetarian and what what has he oh no i
was going to ask you as jeff goldblum
i was just trying to trick you into
favoring us with your impression i'm
like oh we're gonna no the thing about
the thing about doing goldblum at the
time was it's very tactful yeah it's a
lot of like a lot of like hand hand
stuff yeah just oh well
i i did yeah it was pretty much that and
the weird thing about it was
my impressions are so lame that i don't
really know what i'm doing so
it's more of a feeling yeah yeah like
the jeff goldblum feeling and then i
realized okay i'm about to do this
sketch
in front of people live and i don't
really know what i'm doing like man
i'm just hoping that i feel like jeff
goldblum right now
you know what i mean i do i do i i had
to do a brief thing on snl and it was
like i have a similar feeling about it
was matthew mcconaughey and um but it
was just it was so quick my girlfriend
at the time was hosting and they were
having me just do like a quick little
thing and there was so much
pressure on that you know i the fewer
lines you have the the higher the
mistakes and um i remember having that
thought yeah god i hope it's just there
i hope i feel like yeah
because i don't really know what to do
um
yeah it's funny i saw goldblum he is
very tactile he we did a play together
once and i remember him
doing the um he's very into hands
shaking hand oh and
squeezing squeezing the shoulder
um but as as david what did inspire uh
you to become a vegetarian was that
something that your your parents did
well i'm i'm a very lazy vegetarian i
mean i i eat some
some
you know living things you know still
no but the original impetus was uh when
i was in college i read a book called
the diet for a new america which was
which was pretty much like the uh fast
food nation of its of its time
and and it was it was really dark it
really documented the uh
the lives that are that our livestock
have you know and it was it was
i mean i i look around at nature and i
see it's doggy dog and i i see that
things have to die for other things to
live and i that's the way the game is
set up and it sucks but that's the way
the game is set up but
you know that doesn't mean we have to
you know overcrowd these right sensitive
smart animals and make their lives
miserable i keep thinking about that
tennyson line nature is red and tooth
and claw yeah
i just watched this great documentary on
the galapagos it's on the national
geographic channel i think and and
the the blue footed boobies do something
that is so i mean it's so it's beyond
savage it's when you human i was
projecting my own human you know
thoughts emotions it is because they
kick one of the babies out of the nest
and it's it's like cripplingly sad it's
um
but to your point it is that's how it
works i mean it's that's the balance
uh
yeah
and and i think that uh
it's it's just it is it's just too
heartbreaking
to to think about and and i i think back
on like uh in updike's the witches of
eastwood yeah the devil character he
gets up and he gives this long speech at
the end where he pretty much just
chronicles all the hideous things on the
planet like you know worms that go
through your penis uh come out your leg
and he's just like and he's saying and
your god created all those things next
time vote for me ah yes yeah that's
great and yeah and it's it's a
frightening world and it's it's full of
pain and suffering and violence but
you know i think we can mitigate that uh
sometimes if we can well that's all the
time we have on like i don't know
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
this segment is brought to you by bud
light seltzer's new retro summer pack
summer is in full swing
it's the time of summer where i start to
get a little squirrely about going back
to school but then i remember i'm an
adult and i'm not i don't go to school
anymore you know what i think about when
i think of um
summer's gone by i think of
being a kid and being free
and we'd stay out as long as we could
until our mother would call us in for
dinner but here's the one thing that was
missing from
those memories
bud light seltzer now we're able to
drink it responsibly and we can add it
to
uh future summer memories the common
bond that we shared this summer was bud
light seltzer was the new retro summer
pack there's such delicious flavors
there's blue raspberry summer ice which
you love
also if you're not into if you're one of
those people who don't like drinking
beverages
you can enjoy um you can enjoy this
you can have this experience in a
slightly different way you can have bud
light seltzer retro summer icicles which
are basically like an adult version of
freeze pops it's great for a summer day
yeah you can toss a couple in the um in
the cooler if you have a barbecue
they're really easy to carry around and
they come in several out-of-sight
flavors in fact the ones we mentioned
the out-of-sight flavors being blue
raspberry some rice and cherry limeade
so
grab some friends
and grab some of these icicles and enjoy
the vibes so get it delivered right to
your door you find a retailer near you
at bud light.com delivery or
go to your local neighborhood grocery
convenience or liquor store and
get it yourself in person
[Music]
we just have a short lightning round
because i know you you got to go soon um
oh geez lightning round so it's gonna be
a real emphasis on lightning
okay uh
uh okay here we go truly truly like
lightning is is my novel out right now
that i'm developing as a show for
showtime oh i'm starring oh great is
that how's that for like what's great
like a lightning segway self-promotion
like lightning truly like lightly like
yes it's a it's an epic uh western
that's uh on your book stands now how
cool
okay well now knowing your writing work
i want to i want to read that truly like
lightning and it's being developed for
showtime
yeah yeah we're just work we just we're
working on the pilot script now and
hopefully we're going to shoot that next
time how fun to do a western god damn
what i'm embarrassed to ask you this now
what is your most commonly used emoji
i type uh the colon parentheses yeah
smiley old school smiley face
or or old school frowny yeah or winky
you ever do the old school semicolon
winky face
if i'm too lazy to hit the caps
okay
to get the coal um so you just hey we
should we should really end there
because i know
and now we're headed full circle
uh i wish we could we can maybe move
that around in the edit mish if you're
listening yeah um well if you could if
you you had mentioned you played sports
uh but if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would it be either
baseball or basketball
yeah or tennis uh yeah who are your
teams who's your uh you're a yankees fan
uh the net next yankees oh nicks i knew
i feel like i've seen you at those games
yeah yeah yeah i've been i've been uh
lots of next games yeah
uh in the yankees
yankees okay in football you follow
football
[Music]
not really but i i grew up with jets
fans yeah but i i wrote i'm friendly and
in new york yeah um okay if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be
is peanut butter snack food um
i guess so
yeah
so you like p do you in terms of snacks
do you peanut butter out of peanut
butter on apple or peanut butter on
celery okay
you like peanut butter type
sweets like peanut butter i'll eat
peanut butter like if you put my phone
in peanut butter i'll eat the phone okay
wow all right chunky smooth
i had a [ __ ] fight
okay what is give me that do you have a
favorite brand you want to shout out
maybe they'll send you a ton of stuff
i don't i don't i feel like i can afford
oh that's true okay yeah that's a good
there's a good point i haven't learned
that lesson yet i'm still shameless um
what is your um uh
a movie what was what was a movie that
you really uh
was important for you to show your kids
that you were like really excited i
can't wait till they're a certain age
for for them to see this it's like an
important movie to me i want to pass it
down
that i'm in it or just the movies just
any movie that you love um
i think uh as embarrassing as this i
probably feel the dreams for my son
yeah
godfather was always like i always try
to get my kids lost to that problem
oh really
oh man my dad
loved the guy he got me to sit down and
watch it i i also went through a phase
though in high school where i just
wanted to watch everything you know i
was like uh and the more pretentious the
better um
god
what did they do with your you said he
just graduated from high school is he
high school he's planning on going to
college
yeah he's going pittsburgh next year oh
nice um
uh my daughter is
at brown and also acting amazing
yeah about that she's really talented i
bet brown's got a great acting program
you don't have to give them any
endorsement i mean
they they're already fine oh
i thought you're saying i don't endorse
my children no no no i i set you up for
that you that too but it's nice um what
is your go-to they might laugh at this
imagining you doing this your go-to
karaoke song
i don't think because i always had like
a terrible voice nobody ever wanted to
say which is really weird because i make
music now i actually sing oh you know i
record i record music where i'm singing
which is which is the biggest joke
in the history of my work because they
i've worked for
i've really i worked really hard on
trying to you know learn how to use my
voice better now good for you you take
singing lessons
i do no i do i i've takes i've taken
singing lessons for
probably six years now oh wow
and my third album was coming out like
in a couple months wow you are a true
multi-hyphenate what's that what's that
going to be called
it's called gesture land you should uh
check out the first two maybe you'd like
something or maybe you'd hate it i don't
know well hey it's out there now just
just don't tell them how cool yeah well
i probably wouldn't tell you what is
your um unless we really gotta hurt you
just i never heard from justin again
oh he listened to your music well if we
became good friends i would be honest
with you um like what david cut it out
so if you had to sing a karaoke i mean
if now that you have taken the lessons
you could well we have a joke my son and
i have a joke he says africa by toto is
the best song ever written
i love that song
and i've tried to sing that in the car
yeah that is a tough scene well you have
a naturally deeper voice that i would
imagine it gets that gets that concern
he gets up there um
you know in the chorus
yeah i felt i felt some race uh
yeah yeah it's high my brother's saying
that he's gonna love that i'm saying
this he was in a uh an acapella group um
and they sang that uh that's a good
acapella song
yeah i bet but he was a bass at harmony
yeah he's his bass he was a bass so his
was more like how he's gonna like he
went
i felt the reigns i felt
i mean that's high there you go it's
really high um and it's not and it's not
falsettos that's right
god you need to take a ball-peen hammer
to your
yeah
yes help help out i wish i could say his
name now but i i don't want you only
because i said some things that are
probably against hipaa break some hipaa
laws um
who was your first celebrity crush that
you remember your very first oh uh
i had a couple you know not sure
uh
david just shifted in his chair
yeah yeah uh
uh julie newmar catwoman from from
batman sure
uh
dorothy hamill
free olympics yeah i just loved her so
much and then uh linda carter wonder oh
sure that's come up a few times
linda cause i saw her on um
the uh remember that show they used to
have where they'd have the actors uh
compete
like oh the battle of the network stars
yeah yeah i saw her i saw her um compete
in in a swimming race okay and and that
brought on the onset sure you were a big
aquatics fan
uh yeah that's funny they tried to
revive that show david and they couldn't
get i was on a network show i was on an
nbc show at the time and they
um i got so excited because they asked
me to do it i was like seventh or eighth
on the call sheet
and i thought hey they must just like my
stuff i just think i'm yeah and then i i
i somehow let it slip somehow i was like
kind of bragging about it to other
people in the cast and everyone in their
own well but they were all like
yeah they they asked me to do it too i
just realized they couldn't get anybody
to do it you know
if you had to get a tattoo i think you
have tattoos no i have tattoos yeah but
if you had to get another one where
where would you get it and what would it
be
where would i get it well it's a tough
lightning round you know we can skip
just because you're running out of time
i'd say my right ankle because my left
ankle has two so i gotta balance it out
somehow yeah you definitely do
what would it be maybe two maybe the
number two
the number two that's that's perfect
let's move on okay um
uh not my heel uh achilles uh what's
your what's your favorite fruit
well probably uh
apple macintosh macintosh
i know it's weird i'm very very in the
minority okay yeah you certainly are not
to shame you for your answer yeah wrong
answers uh who do you want who would you
want to play you and your biopic
i want to play me and my david
story
yeah
uh
i don't know man
uh i don't know
moving on okay if that if nothing comes
maybe it means you have to play yourself
you should play yourself
yeah well you know they they're
the technology's getting that's true
though that's true
um and who is your uh who's your
favorite simpsons character you've been
on the simpsons right
yeah but i'm not a huge some sort of
watcher but oh okay but i like uh
what do i like
you played i don't know you played
mulder
yeah and i had like an id with being a
bathing suit oh
that was yeah that was the big show yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
what are people what is an assumption
that people have about you that you
would like to debunk i mean when
somebody approaches you or you've heard
people say oh you're surprisingly this
or that
i think people uh
i don't want to use the word arrogant
[Laughter]
you're more arrogant than people think
yeah exactly
um maybe it's maybe i'm just guarded
yeah yeah it comes off it comes off as
judgmental i'm not really i'm not really
i'm not really judging you i'm just i'm
afraid oh interesting interesting um
well i'm judging you and i'm afraid of
you um
dogs are cats
oh dogs yeah yeah yeah um beetles don't
question
like they haven't heard in a while that
oh [ __ ] that hasn't been on in a while
the long and winding road i like very
much yeah um
well this i i this road could have been
longer i like that it was a little windy
it wasn't just a direct uh insertion
um thanks for doing this and best of
luck with the the reservoir um
it's a short form fiction it's uh on
it's an auto audible original
yeah and you have to you have to finish
it now i know i will well i will i just
started last night
and then you have like a little a little
footnote on this uh and you say i
finished it and it was wonderful
okay
and i wish that i would have asked david
this about it
yeah but i can't yeah and that's and and
that's my fault and then we'll get
justin that's
and then i'll get wistful like that i
mean i like that you're giving me a line
reading but i'm gonna get even more
wistful i'm gonna i'll be i promise to
be better i promise
and he and i'm sorry i judged him for
all those years uh but i was just afraid
i was afraid he wasn't nearly as
arrogant so somewhat arrogant but not um
just yeah just well he was arrogant
enough really yeah
perfect no you were right this was
this was great i really enjoyed this
thank you
thank you
[Music]
so so that just happened so that just
happened that's pretty good well you
know i naturally sound a bit like him
you
do i know
um yeah well he's
you guys have a similar range i've i've
always thought that about him that he is
and i can say this because i think i'm
similar
um so i'm not insulting him he's very
monotone
yeah very monotone to the point where
it's always been surprising to me that
he's a performer in the first place i
think he's a very good actor but i know
he does not have the personality or the
um expressiveness i know
you know i wanted to agree with him but
he seems like like a very con very
confident person somebody who if you
were to agree with that he wouldn't be
insulted and i don't think he'd be
insulted hearing what do i know but i
feel like i know him a little bit i
don't think so and and i knew
um yeah he was very dry he's very
monotone but he's extremely i think
charming very and funny oh my god very
extremely funny and i knew that i've
talked before i listened to this
conversation i already knew that yeah
anytime he's on
a late show late night talk show i'm
always impressed by how funny he's
always so charming but but you know it
like betrays his
monotone no it's true well it's that
he's able to do uh have this great dry
delivery he delivers everything in a
very dry because that's his natural um
and so it sort of sneaks up on you i
love that kind of funny person where
they're not really like selling things
and they're yeah he's very sharp
speaking of sneaking up on
things sneaking up on you um you
launched into your prostate exam at the
very start
of the interview
and it reminded me of
so excited to talk about it it reminded
me of when
you're in high school
like a sophomore in high school and you
make out with a girl at a party or
something and you're so excited to tell
your friends about it that was the
energy you had i don't remember being
excited to tell friends about that
really no i
i was also a little bit behind the
you know
the rest of the guys in terms of likes
you had that energy you were like okay
so guess where i just came
you were like excited to talk about i
was too because i i knew that i i guess
because i'd seen him on talk shows i
felt like he was the kind of guy that i
would be cool to talk about that kind of
stuff i guess it could have been anyone
because i really like it so on my mind
and when something like that happens to
you you know it's like you don't just i
mean i'm sure one day by my like 12th
prostate check i'll be like oh yeah
whatever it's similar to the testicle
exam it's because now i'm like i'm not
coming home i'm not needing to talk
about that afterwards unless something
funny happens right right but i think
the funniest stuff that happens with
that is that did i tell you that he our
doctor talked about the jets while it
was happening no that's funny oh yeah he
was as he was you know feeling for
which all men should get you should get
their testicles checked um
uh scrotal cancers and stuff um but he
was talking about how hopefully it was
for the chats how their coach robert
saleh and and i was too we're all chats
fans i think or i mean chet's fans are
always hopeful but i remember once i was
getting a testicle check and i was you
know you have to turn your head and
cough and i and they kept saying he and
my doctor at the time my pediatrician i
was young i was maybe 14. you kept
saying where your testicles were uh is
around the time yeah uh any any and he
kept saying cough harder just cough
harder because you know you have to
because you have to really test for um
the hernia especially if you have little
testicles okay
so i caught so i kept coughing as hard
as i could to the point was like hurting
my throat i remember and he was like a
little bit harder and i coughed as hard
as i could and i farted so loudly at the
same time
because like every i was pushing
everything so hard what yeah i never
told you that no
and he got like he kind of smiled
as if that's not embarrassing i know it
is i know and he's right there he's he's
fart level
oh my god
that's amazing what did you say did you
it was really embarrassing oh my god do
you address it i mean i never know no i
think i i mean
i'm sure a lot of people would but i'm
not the kind of person especially then
but even now i i'm not i feel like i
would try to let as much go as possible
if something like that happened i think
he was a little irked that you hadn't
uh listened to his entire i do get that
impression yeah i do too and he was like
playful about it at the end but yeah he
there was some truth in that he was like
uh maybe next time you'll
you know look yourself in the mirror and
think about what you did wrong yeah
maybe listen to the whole thing next
time and there was truth in it i think
and i
i get why he might have been a little
annoyed yeah like why not i mean they
sent us i had it sorry david
it's a really good piece though you
should listen to it yeah okay you don't
have to
continue to shame me uh yeah he was a
little irked um also he did not seem to
enjoy the lightning round no but he was
good at it he was good at it but it
seemed like you know
it made me feel insecure a little bit
about the questions about the nature of
the lightning round and some of the
questions because he's so smart and kind
of intimidatingly so
that when people like that are
dismissive of things like that it makes
me think uh it's not it's kind of
valuable it's kind of stupid no but see
that's interesting that he because he's
so bright that says something about him
it's like he couldn't be bothered it was
too basic yeah exactly yeah yeah but um
you know i'm now that you mentioned the
thing about the book not the book the
audible original um i didn't mean not
finishing it i'm really glad that my
real fear was that i would get called
out for not having seen the x-files
you've never seen the x-files i i've
seen bits and pieces of it but i've
never really start to finish i watched
an episode whoa i did love california
that movie you've never seen that no
yeah it's great with um a young brad
pitt and juliette lewis they played a
like a bonnie and clyde young brad pitt
yeah but hard to beat a young brad pitt
no i know but he was he was so good in
it he was so believably like uh rough
around the edges and i don't mean that
in like a james dean type way he was
like skeezy looking you know like mom
would have said about him um
he seems dirty he looks dirty you know
he's got that like hit that patchy
facial hair and like he looked like a
real scumbag in it huh he's great in it
juliet lewis is amazing she we should
try to get her on the show oh thanks for
the a cappella shout out
um
i'm curious to hear his music now me too
because he was pretty down on his
singing voice but he's been working at
it i know um i'm cute really curious to
hear his music i've never heard of it i
know
i mean it might be a little bit like uh
you know what it sounds like remember
that song uh she grew up and the
children of the stars yeah and the
boulevard
everything's gonna be all right remember
that yeah
don't i sound exactly yeah but he sounds
like he could do stuff like that like
she grew up or like crash test dummies
covers that's that's so insulting he can
do more than that i bet no but that's
what his voice sounds like it would lend
himself to mm-hmm he has like uh he
really does have uh
it's pretty good right who else does he
sound like a little bit like uh like
john crine a little john prine yeah or
charles grodin
what a loss um should we read a letter
yeah this is from corey smith
subject when the rabbit met the mouse
wow curious hi justin and christian i've
been listening to the podcast since day
one oh man thanks corey two years do you
know when day one was uh may
4
i think it's 13th 13th almost at 14th
2019. wow does that sound like a long
time ago it does which is scary um
he's been listening since may 13th um
back to cory maybe even sooner oh since
i was a fan since the promo for the
podcast that's amazing
i couldn't tell you when that was i've
been a huge fan of justin's for a long
time now thanks corey i'm currently
listening to the eric bowser episode and
i had to write in i'm completely blown
away by his amazing ability to
transition from character to character
yeah that was
i
i've been trying not to use the word
amazing as much because i think it gets
overused and it's not but uh i think
that's appropriate amazing it is um it
really hit home for me because like you
said we grew up with the warner brothers
characters but especially for me because
my late grandmother retired as the head
of imagineering over at disney wow and
married a big wig who worked at the wb
the subject line is the inside joke we
set around the house these characters
made such a huge impact in my life and
listening to him bring them back to life
in such a surprising way brought a huge
smile to my face wait what was the
subject again the subject line um oh
the subject line is when the rabbit met
the mouse
oh so disney and and warner brothers
that's funny uh
this turned a horrible day into a great
one i'm definitely going to have a
listen to this once again
thanks for all the laughs and the humble
conversations you've really humanized a
lot of your guests for me
i see these big stars in a whole new
light thanks again for everything corey
what a nice letter
god thank you corey um
and then he says would you rather great
okay
just made a nice letter a great letter
would you rather know every mistake
you're gonna make prior to making them
with no way to prevent them oh wow or
have every mistake you've ever made
replaying your head without you ever
able to forget them i would pick the
first one um
rather i would rather know every mistake
i'm going to make prior to making them
with no way to prevent them because
then you can at least think about how
best to mitigate the effects of those
mistakes you know
but but you can do that regardless
because the effect of the mistake
once the mistake is made
you're gonna it's something you'll have
to deal with regardless of whether you
know about it beforehand or not right i
guess so but so you will really be able
to mitigate it before you make it
because you're gonna make it anyway no i
guess mitigate the the the after i mean
afterwards you'll be able to prepare for
how best to
you know um
ease the the whatever
consequences there there were i mean or
did am i saying that properly like i'm
trying to think of a mistake that
uh
let's see what's a mistake that i'd be
making like i'm running a second cup of
coffee before good good point okay so
um i i would know that it's going to be
a mistake so
in cory's would you rather i would have
seen that i'd be a little bit too
jittery and juiced up
but wouldn't it be just to play devil's
advocate wouldn't it be really
frustrating to know that that was gonna
be the result and you're still doing it
wouldn't that drive you crazy it would
see that's why i would pick the second
one because they replay in your head
that means it's hard to be present then
well that's what i was going to say i
think it depends on
what that means by playing your head and
it doesn't necessarily mean playing in
your head in a regretful way a shameful
way exactly that's true it could just be
the memory is there playing
oh you know what i see this in a new
light now i just uh i just something got
clarified for me which is
i think that might be in a way
beneficial
to have those mistakes replaying your
head uh without being able to forget
them because then you learn from them
exactly but here's the problem if if
they're replaying too aggressively in
your head then like you said before it
would be hard to be present because
that's the only thing you're thinking
about oh yeah
that's so it depends on how much they're
in your head i wouldn't mind
if i was just cognizant of these things
of mistakes i've made because like you
said then you can use that exactly and
try to prevent a future mistake yeah
that's why i'm talking and then the goal
would be to make no mistake yeah or
fewer mistakes
well i we've talked about this before
like i when people say no regrets in
life i have no regrets i
i don't know that that's the most i do
have regrets and i i don't and there was
a long time where i tried to forget
about them or i tried and i think you
you do ultimately need to
put them process them in a way where you
can be present and not dwell on them
certainly that's what somebody like
deepak chopra would probably say also
there's something so um contrary to the
human experience
if you
know what's going to happen before it
happens you know it's like i know i
wouldn't want to exist in a way that was
all you know
faded out for me well i've thought about
this a lot like the that christopher
walken movie that stephen king book uh
what is it is it the dead zone uh where
he touches somebody and knows can see
how they're gonna die oh yeah see their
future
thought about that a lot like would you
want to know
your death and when you're going to die
would you if you
couldn't prevent it
uh no i wouldn't right yeah yeah so that
speaks to this right yeah i wouldn't
want to know the mistakes i'd make
either
[Music]
i especially if there's nothing i can do
to prevent them exactly if they're going
to happen
they might as well happen and then i'll
deal with the ramifications
ramifications i changed my answer i i
cory i think i would is it fair to say
that i talked you into a new answer yeah
but and also like i'm you know this is a
mistake i made just now that i'd like to
make uh i'd like to not make in the
future i've been doing it on the show
lately is i don't think enough about
them i i jump into the first one that
that peaks my uh
fancy fancy peaks
would you say
that's what you do in general in life uh
probably react too quickly probably yeah
i thought i had gotten better at it i
think i've gotten better at it but uh
here's an example of how i have not
grown much well here's uh where i would
you fleshed it out you have grown
the fact that you're even talking about
wanting to be better at it
so that right there is growth yes yes
yes 43 now and you know
evolving 43 god that's mid-40s you know
no i think it's still early no i don't
think so i think early 40s is 40 41 42
mid is 43 44 45 46 well i think 43 is
like no man's land between young early
and mid
i think i i'll give you this
when i'm half 43 and a half then i'll be
mid but give me six months so four i'll
give you this you're sniffing 50.
sniffing 50 no way i'm sniffing mid-40s
you sure are yeah god didn't have it
doesn't that sound crazy crazy life is
short life is short okay well thanks for
listening by the way
yeah and thank you for um writing in
corey and if you guys would like to
write in and be the next corey
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com
what does corey smith remind me of isn't
there a there's a wider tory smith tory
smith toy smith yeah very tragically
i'll never forget this when tory smith
lost his mother do you remember this no
or his sister maybe no
you don't remember it either well
someone very close to tom and then had
to play the next day and
dominated he's a hell of a player tory
smith god i can't wait for football huh
me too so uh thanksgiving david duke yes
the jets fan chad's fan yeah and nick's
fan and we'll uh talk to you next week
yeah hopefully
stop saying that why are you saying if
they wanna listen we're going to be here
oh i see i see
we'll be talking so nervous i know it's
scary it's like it sounds very
fatalistic
we'll be talking to them yes but you're
saying hopefully they'll listen exactly
okay bye
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
longchats fan it's co-hosted and
produced by you also jets fan christian
law and it's also produced by megan v
monaco not sure what her team
affiliation is senior producer is
michelle miesh lans audio engineer
sergio enriquez and executive producer
is marshall louie i think he's a rams
fan i'm not sure don't hold me to that i
would guess he's a rams fan too marshall
if you're listening to this let us know
what your affiliation is are you excited
about matthew stafford
for wondering
[Music]
okay it was it was and the craziest
thing to me is that it was all during
the pandemic right
all this
all this um
conception happened during the pandemic
so in january of this year
six months ago
he had another daughter with
brittany bell the same woman he had the
son with four years ago right
fine okay second kid together it's been
four years still seemingly together
after four years great
then what happens in june of that year
six months later
he has
twin boys
with a different model
abby de la rosa
which means that when
brittany bell his girlfriend of years
is pregnant with their second kid
together he slept with
six months pregnant
he slept around with
this influencer abby taylor rose who got
pregnant right
as if that's not crazy enough
two weeks
after he cheated on her and slept with
this influencer abby taylor rosa
he slept with another model no named
alyssa scott no
so
that all this infidelity yielded this
in january he had a daughter of this
girlfriend in june early june he had
twin boys
with this other model
and then in mid-june two weeks later
he had another boy with his current
girlfriend
so he had these three girls he was
juggling these models
and he's now settling on this one alyssa
scott
why in the world would she trust him
she should
that's crazy it's crazy to do it once
with
one other girl
to be like you have a pregnant
girlfriend
and you're like been pregnant someone
else while your girlfriend's pregnant
but to do that twice
so he has three pregnant girlfriends at
the same time
what is he like genghis khan it's insane
congratulations
[Music]
and it's just like yay cannon is a
father again
look at alyssa's baby bump
like making it all cute he's like a
maniac
oh my god wobby
you